pues ustedes ya lo mencionaban
previamente ya nancy pelosi la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes- amenazó hace meses
recientemente esta tarde con que si no
se lleva a cabo y si no se implementa la
enmienda 25 ella pues hará todo lo
posible para que donald trump sea
nuevamente tenga que pasar por un
proceso de impeachment esto quiere decir
que si el vicepresidente no toma el
poder de la casablanca ella empezará un
proceso de impeachment el segundo
recordemos que ya había empezado uno en
el 2018 lo que ha dicho
donald trump es que pues y se ha dicho
que él se lo ha conversado con varios
asesores de él es que él se daría el
auto perdón lo mencionó lo empezó a
mencionar justo después de haber perdido
la elección el 3 de noviembre y vuelven
a surgir las voces de fuentes anónimas
de la casa blanca diciendo que el
presidente de froome está considerando
fuertemente auto perdonarse antes de
salir de la casa blanca para no tener
que asumir crímenes federales sin
embargo
no lo escapa de los crímenes estatales
que por ejemplo enfrenta en estados como
nueva york'
cristóbal hablemos de facebook instagram
twitter y es que es histórico también
que las redes sociales tomarán acción
contra los comunicados de trump cuál es
la última información que tiene sobre la
suspensión de las cuentas del presidente
saliente
si de hecho mark zuckenberg si hoy
fundador de facebook dice que tras la
incitación del presidente saliente de
donald trump a estos miembros de grupos
terroristas domésticos como lo dice joe
biden pues entonces la plataforma social
le cancela le suspende las redes
sociales al presidente hasta el 20 de
enero que deje el poder porque según
zuckerberg el presidente está usando sus
últimos días en la casa blanca para
incitar a violencia y para evitar que se
haga una transición pacífica de poder
michelle obama es otra de las voces que
se suma a esta petición de que tanto
twitter como facebook como otras
plataformas sociales de redes sociales
bloqueen al presidente dice michelle
obama que no pueden servir está
aplastada estas plataformas sociales
como un megáfono para la violencia hay
que resaltar también que en los últimos
minutos se conoció que hay interés por
parte de él en sao que es la secretaria
de transporte de donald trump que ha
sido secretaria de transporte desde que
empezó en
2016 pues estaría con intereses de
retirarse del gobierno bien cristóbal
vázquez gracias por tu reporte